scary scene to see like I said even if
it wasn't my family member but for it to
be my nephew it was just that much more
gut-wrenching to to see that Demar him
Uncle Dorian Glenn was watching the
bills Bengals game with family members
in Pittsburgh when he saw his nephew
collapse we went from trying to console
his little brother to the whole living
room was crying we were all in tears on
the field medical personnel quickly
began CPR before taking Hamlin to the
hospital if not for what they did my
nephew be dead right now Glenn said
Hamlet has lung damage and can't breathe
on his own he was receiving 100 oxygen
from a ventilator but now that's down to
only 50 percent his heart went out twice
went out on the field when they
resuscitated him and then when he got
back to the hospital went out a second
time and they had to hit him with the
defibrillator around Cincinnati fans
gathered for the 24 year old a vigil
outside the hospital took a moment of
silence at 8 55 the time Hamlin
collapsed Monday night